J Janice behemoth was one of the new
Titans that were awakened by Ghidorah
alpha call this Titan was first seen in
the movie as an elephant like Titan that
walk on all four of its limbs but even
though it looked like a mammoths slash
sloth it walked more like a gorilla it
was a mammalian Titan resembling the
gigantic [ __ ] like knuckle walks like
an ape using his long four limbs which
are larger than his legs behemoths most
notable traits on his colossal mammoth
like tusks which jumped downwards from
his cheeks
but unlike a mammoth or an elephant he
lacks a trunk thus Titan is covered in
light brown fur and appears to have
greenish vines or algae growing on his
otherwise greatest behemoths possess a
row of bumpy triangular spikes running
along his back he is very tall and
appears to nearly match Godzilla himself
in physical stature he was discovered by
Moana in Brazil and an outpost was
constructed around him he is contained
and monitored in monarch outposts 58 in
a cavern in the tent were preserved in
Brazil and was designated as Titanes
behemoth hidden Godzilla king of the
monsters the official movie novelization
ization and monarch agent named Mariko
states that there are cave paintings of
him that are 12,000 years old behemoths
fur is essentially fireproof as fire
cannot burn on it very little of the
heat from the fire there was a result of
military attacks actually effects
behemot skin which makes it merely an
irritation behemoths can use his strong
and sharp just to destroy buildings with
ease he can also attack with his claws
on his front limbs while standing on his
hind legs he is named after a beast
mentioned in the Bible which is
interpreted often as either referring to
a mythical creature or a large animal
such as an elephant or a rhinoceros the
official movie novelization also gives
behemoth an alternative name mapinguari
derived from a brazilian cryptid
according to native folklore mapinguari
was a creature that has a series of
unnatural characteristics these include
a creature only having one eye long
claws lizard light skin backward feet
and a second mouth on his belly it has
consistently been described as
resembling either an ape or a giant
ground dwelling slop and have our arms
powerful claws that could tear apart
small trees
popping back and covered in thick matted
fur so no wonder the item was named as
such because it had a tusk the gigantic
size and sloth-like appearance account
state that it gave off a putrid stench
and emitted a frightening streak and
that weapon such as arrows and bullets
could not penetrate the mapinguaris
alligator like high it's only known
weakness is that it avoids bodies of
water
behemoth was among the many titles
awakened from his slumber in Brazil
Viking vidura's alpha call more not
prepared to terminate behemoth when he
responded to guitarist call however an
agent named Mariko who sympathized with
Emma Russell's mission and believed
behemoth to be the most interesting of
all the Titans cut the power to the
outpost backup kill switch behemoths
quickly dispatched a group of soldiers
and a nozzle emitting blue-white fire
before breaking out of the facility
killing Mariko in the process he
attacked Rio de Janerio
before making his way to Boston along
with Methuselah Scylla and a six-legged
muta there they found the alpha they
were following Ghidorah slain at the
hands of Godzilla Rodin approached
Godzilla to challenge him but was
intimidated by his gaze and ultimately
submitted the other Titans all followed
suit each bowing in their own way to the
new king of the monsters news outlets
reported afterwards that behemoths trail
of destruction had begun to restore
clear-cut parts of the Amazon rainforest
in the credits scene it was shown that
all the titles were converging on Skull
Island the question now stands at how
good tight-ass behemoth cross thousands
of kilometers of ocean when his Anatomy
isn't clearly built for swimming long
distances so be sure to like share
subscribe for more videos and do click
on a notification bell for regular and
actual notifications